good morning everyone we are going to
get started with our day we have a full
day and a very exciting day looking at
not only borderline personality disorder
and understanding it supporting
individuals with its supporting
providers doing their best to help
supporting family members who who care
so deeply and are often at such a loss
of how to do that and how to take care
of themselves it's very exciting to have
people here for those topics and not
only those but to explore one area that
could be particularly challenging that
can show up which is in addition to the
things that we often think about with
borderline personality disorder emotions
getting out of control behaviors getting
out of control one aspect of these
difficulties is what sometimes referred
to as cognitive dysregulation there's
different ways that difficulties in
thinking can occur and we're going to be
looking here at a variety of challenges
that can happen in thinking we have
different presenters who have expertise
who will address different types of
difficulties some more closely related
to borderline personality disorder some
that might co-occur with borderline
personality disorder so that will be our
focus today I I'm Seth Axelrod I'm a
associate professor in the School of
Medicine I lead DBT programming in our
adult intensive outpatient program I
would like to say in terms of the
mission of this conference in terms of
of doing the various things we do to
raise awareness and support the various
parties again providers researchers
individuals struggling family members
even in the last 24 hours I've run into
incidents of the need for this kind of
work I received one email from a family
member who has been struggling with
on their child at their wit's end
nothing making sense and had just
recently discovered this thing called
borderline personality disorder and was
able to find the book on that sherry
Manning put out loving someone with
borderline personality disorder and
suddenly everything started to click and
suddenly this person was had hope for
that this is something that could be
understood there could be treatment I
believe the it's family member may have
come today but I was so grateful to have
the opportunity to offer something and
so grateful to have my collaboration
with Perry Hoffman and with the national
education alliance to offer conferences
like these and that there are that there
is information through this through
family connections other other things
through their organization to help
family members so I was it was it was a
wonderful thing to have that also it
within the last day I've had individuals
struggle with borderline personality
disorder bring things to my attention
that speak to the problems of stigma the
portrayals of borderline that currently
exists in our culture one involves a
current criminal case where the
prosecution raises the diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder to
discredit on the person on trial and
that person may be guilty but it again
adds to the stigma that somehow
borderline personality disorder is an
explanation perhaps for heinous acts and
that's very hurtful because that's
that's not there's no reason to believe
that this disorder translates into the
level of destruction and and criminal
behavior that occurred another
individual brought to my attention the
Time magazine just put out a spread on
the mind and on disorders but their
portrayal borderline personality
disorder included descriptions of that
individuals when they try to hug
one they claw them that they're that
their affections are so harsh and that
the disorder is is relatively
intractable and it makes things
impossible for family members and is
untreatable and that the article did go
on and discuss some things related to
hope to discuss some things related to
advances but even there got a lot of the
information wrong so so even the hopeful
message was inaccurate and speaks to our
need to educate ourselves and to help
educate our community about what this
disorder actually is and what the what
the current sciences and the treatments
i would i'd like to give some thanks to
people in organizations that are we see
here i'm realizing i am not sure how to
dance and ease this one this will work
no trying to go to the next slide do i
oh I know what I'm doing here we go
excuse me excuse me one moment for
technical difficulties there we go I've
acknowledged national education alliance
they are primary co-sponsors providers
of these conferences will be hearing in
a moment welcoming remarks from
president of national education alliance
Perry Hoffman I also want to acknowledge
yale-new Haven psychiatric hospital for
supporting this conference yell stress
center and Yale School of Medicine in
addition to our our village who helps
make this conference happen including my
conference coordinators I couldn't have
a more dedicated team our conference
staff as well and a whole group a large
group of volunteers you'll see running
around doing all kinds of conference
tasks I'd like to share a few business
ethan's before we go into our further
welcomes and our first talk one is one
question that often comes up our
referrals you'll be hearing about the
possibilities of treatments and people
often come here looking for referrals
I'm going to encourage you to visit our
exhibitors we have several specialty
programs who have representatives who
focus on on really helping individuals
with borderline included among them our
exhibitors we have a table with services
from yelling leavin hospital they are
also aware of other services in this
geographic area so if people are looking
for referrals I encourage you to go that
table in particular to learn about local
resources I'd like to mention that we
have a mixed audience that this we
deliberately include clinicians mental
health training those who are in
training to become professionals or are
developing their skills individuals who
have struggled with mental health issues
and particularly problems of borderline
personality disorder related and family
members of those supporting so I i I'm
grateful to have all this representation
but also want to acknowledge that there
may be different needs that are here and
I want to encourage people who are if
people find themselves personally
affected by things that you here that's
important to take care of yourself it's
important to if you need to take breaks
from a talk if you need to reach out to
your support so use your skills
encourage it to be aware things can be
sensitive here and I encourage our
speakers we will all do our best to
speak sensitively about the issues we
discuss for family members you'll be
hearing from a family member who is who
has gone through something that may be
similar to what you've gone through I
encourage you to check out the resources
through the national education alliance
that may also be helpful in addition to
this conference for professionals most
of most of you in this crowd are
professionals many of you are we'll get
continuing education credits for being
here we expectations that everyone sign
in when you came into the conference if
you want credit you haven't
lined in on the next break please go
back and they'll you know sign in but
also make sure to sign out I believe
that we are going to be delivering the
continuing education credits for nurses
at the end of the conference I believe
that's correct so it's you need to be
here until the very end of the
conference to sign out and get your
credit we have a little more flexibility
with social work if you sign in and sign
out I believe we can give you credit for
the amount of the conference you're here
of course we hope you're here for the
entire day but we know there's some
people who cannot please be aware of
where exits are in case we should need
them please turn off your cell phones
that's much appreciated as it turns out
the reception down here is pretty lousy
and we'll probably run down your battery
anyway so go ahead and turn off your
cell phones disclosures we've asked all
our presenters to disclose any conflicts
of interest there there aren't any
conflicts of interest I listed one
potential one which is that I do I
contract with Marshall Indians
behavioral tech it's not really a
conflict I don't think but just to make
you aware that that I could be paid for
delivering trainings relate to something
so hear about and with that I'd like to
move forward with our other opening
remarks and welcomes and I'd like to
share a public service announcement are
we
okay okay I think where are we there
okay this is a recent public service
announcement by the national education
alliance for borderline person I
disorder after we hear that is we will
welcome dr. Perry Hoffman president of
national education alliance on the
forefront of advocacy for borderline
personality disorder in many national
organization Sam's National Institute of
Mental Health has gotten a me to
recognize borderline as chronic mental
illness among her various other
recognitions and accomplishments they're
wrong 15 million Americans along with
their family suffer with borderline
personality disorder now finally there
is hope aunt house
with treatment improvement just one year
education families face a brighter
future if you are a loved one's impacted
we're here yes contact the national
education alliance with borderline
personality disorder at NBA vpg calm it
will change your life one final
announcement before dr. Hoffman joins us
at the time actually if Perry would come
join us please do is that we do have a
full house we have more people coming
we're not at the point that every seat
is sold but we've actually got a pretty
a pretty big crowd so I would invite
people if you were willing to move in
towards the center to make it easier for
more people that are coming to to get
two seats please do if you're having
trouble if you're in the auditorium
having trouble finding seats there are
plenty of seats available so please do
come and find a seat and I invite dr.
Perry Hoffman to come join us thanks
Seth and good morning and welcome it's
really just wonderful to be here this is
the ninth conference that we have done
with Yale and I am proud and honored to
be the president of the national
education alliance for borderline
personality disorder we're an
organization that was started 12 years
ago by family members consumers and one
mental health professional and wee bit
we've been able to move beyond our
initial dream which was to start an
organization in a small way that would
could perhaps help family members and
from that we've sort of spun into
becoming I'd like to say almost the
nation's voice on borderline personality
disorder in the work that wonderful
families have done this PSA that you
just saw was done totally voluntarily by
a family connections leader which is one
of our programs that we do a man who is
a film editor he put this all together
if we were to pay for something like
this probably fifty thousand dollars so
this is what our organization is about
we're about all volunteers none of us
paid but our effort is to put borderline
personality disorder on the map and in
that we have hosted over 50 conferences
we have a weekly call in series which
someone stopped me this morning and said
I cannot believe that series it's every
sunday night it's all the best
researchers and clinicians that you'll
ever want to hear we send out a
PowerPoint presentation the week of that
their call and people just jump on the
call dr. Jim brailing formerly of an
ni-mh the National Institute of Mental
Health moderate sit but we invite all of
you to join that call if you'd like to
learn more on a weekly basis about the
disorder and you can send us an email at
any AVP d @ aol.com i'm hoping through
today you'll learn even more about the
disorder and also have an opportunity
perhaps to meet some of our family
connections leaders this is a 12-week
course that we offer at no charge to
family members across the country some
of whom participate by telephone because
we don't have leaders in every area of
the country but particularly we do have
some wonderful leaders up here at Yale
there's a new group starting so for
anybody who'd like to join please also
send an email to any a BPD @ aol.com so
again welcome to this wonderful
conference next year will be the 10th
year and I started to look up what 10th
is I know it's not diamonds but it's
something we'll have to figure what it's
what it is and from there we'll we'll
plan an even more remarkable conference
than the last nine so thank you seth and
thank you for all of you for being here
and i hope you have a wonderful day and
gained even more information on this
very treatable disorder my last comment
is that may is BPD Awareness Month we
have wristbands I was hoping to bring
some today but our second order didn't
come in yet but if you'd like to order
one and honor may as BPD awareness month
please again send an email to any a BPD
@ aol.com so thank
you